here is Ron Johnson basically being
gaslit by Chuck Todd about media
partisanship and bias as I've been
saying lately the Republicans are
growing balls and it's freaking people
out
I I'm concerned about getting the truth
I don't Tark individuals Target
individuals
Senator you're targeting an individual
Chuck my concern you know Chuck you know
part of the problem and this is pretty
obvious to anybody watching this is you
don't invite me on to interview me you
invite me on to argue with me you know
I'm just trying to lay out the facts
that certainly Senator grass and I
uncovered they were suppressed they were
censored they interfered in the 2020
election conservatives understand that
unfortunately liberals in the media
don't and that's part of the things that
part of the reasons are politics are
inflamed is we do not have an unbiased
uh media we don't it's unfortunate I'm
all for a free press more unbiased
there's misinformation
look you can go back on your partisan
cable a cocoon and talk about media bias
all you want I understand it's part of
your identity let me move to
Chuck Todd man you are terrible
you are absolutely terrible Chuck Todd I
don't pretend to be a journalist I don't
I suppose at some level some version of
what I'm doing here has something to be
something related to journalism but what
I am doing is I am trying to see what's
going on out into the world trying to
give people an honest assessment of it
not hiding what my biases are I
obviously tell you what my opinions are
and it's very clear what he does as a
quote journalist this is someone who
pretends to be a journalist he works at
a giant Corporation he puts on his suit
he points with the pen and he pretends
that he is unbiased so at the end there
you go back to your biased cocoon oh you
are the biased cocoon man it's just that
mirror thing that I keep talking about
these people just need a mirror
everything they accuse everyone else of
is exactly what they're guilty of Ron
Johnson was just laying out facts there
here's what we know was going on right
here is the fact that we know Hunter
Biden was involved in some level of sex
trafficking because of the information
we found found out on the laptop the
laptop that was censored by big Tech
that you guys all pretended to ignore
that Chuck Todd I have no doubt we can
probably find video on this at the
height of the whole thing there is no
doubt that Chuck Todd was one of the
people promoting that idea that you know
the 50 FBI agents or what was it the 50
CIA operatives Intelligence Officers who
all said it was Russian misinformation
and then of course it was not
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]